you mentioned this question in your Ted
Talk is
the two possibilities
of the universe being full of life
and the universe being empty and we're
the only life in the universe
how do you feel about both options
just actually you as a single chemical
organism introspecting about its
existence in this world it's having a
planet flow of life is interesting
because there are we talked about
life being all about chemistry exploring
Solutions and having Solutions in front
of you is is great it's beneficial right
Solutions being different organisms like
other humans you see them as a solutions
to a chemistry problem different
different yeah that's an interesting
Solution that's not next time we're in
Austin so there's a bunch of weirdos
every time I see a weirdo I'd be like oh
that's an interesting solution to this
chemistry problem
so now you think like an origin of
Lifestyle but it's funny that that one
worked out let's see where else it goes
but having just
emptiness and unpredictability of
uncovering a novel solution can also
have its own benefits and and we should
uh
be open to
what other Solutions might be out there
and exploring those Solutions okay
different chemistry problems so that's
where you see you see the other planets
out there as different chemistry
problems to their own local environment
yes so how many chemistry problems
have solutions that are lifelike to you
out there in the universe
wide open palette if you think about it
I don't quite know it's the we know the
the chemistry is chemistry I don't think
the chemistry will be different
elsewhere but again what is selected by
chemistry will be determined by the
environment most likely see I think
there is a life
everywhere out there
so there's a guy named Nick Lane
whose gut and it's interesting to me I
wonder what you think about it his gut
is there's life everywhere out there but
it stops at like the bacteria stage so
he says that you you eukaryotes
is like the biggest invention and the
hardest one I wonder if he thinks that's
an accidental outcome if he thinks
that's inevitable I wonder what that
means but it's it's very it's a likely
possibility that the uh bacterial or
microbial life is definitely more
attainable
um so that that's a weird world where
our entire galaxy just says but our
bacteria everywhere so you know if you
don't like microbes you aren't on the
wrong planet
and viruses I don't know which one is
more of but they're they're both and
most of them are like productive they're
fascinating they do everything for us
like bankruptcy on the wrong planet
uh you're full of good lines okay right
right I just can't there's like an
imperative to the whole thing to me the
origin
is the hard question but once it gets
going I just don't see them wait it
seems like it's constantly creating more
intelligent things
more
fascinating complex things they're able
to solve that's a video that's a very
interesting like that's I I definitely
agree that the initial steps may be the
ultimate determinants that once it's you
cannot stop it once it starts it's
possible
right and um I just have never on Earth
maybe but maybe
I just whenever I see life it seems to
flourish
everywhere
it the thing is I don't the only thing I
haven't seen is the start of it
exactly but that and how are we gonna
understand that if we don't the origin
of life science I mean that's the and
and the question here isn't exactly our
ability to recapitulate everything that
happened in the exact way that it
happened right this is about what can
happen rather than and or maybe how yeah
you think it is possible to study the
origin of language using English
so
like there's a very particular chemistry
here there's a particular set of
assumptions understanding about what
life is what everything is our
perception of reality is very
specifically constructed through the
evolutionary process I wonder if it's
possible to get to some first principles
deep understanding of
how life originates in such a way that
you can actually construct it on other
planets I ultimately it feels like if
you're doing it in the lab on Earth
you're always going to be using some
aspect of the life that's already here
so
that's what I sort of talked about in my
talk as well
and um everyone should go
watch the TED Talks very good the
annoying thing to me about TED Talks I
guess this by Design is they're too
short it's like come on
and did you know that there's no
prompter involved
there's no wait there is or there isn't
yeah you have to memorize stuff yeah
it's a
editor who probably is watching this too
David bielo it was very very helpful but
I would say that National Organization I
like this podcast it's a very
professional organization I respect that
Medium uh yeah anyway the in the in the
time to talk about yeah life
life creating life so it's a likely
scenario that once we understand how
life
is a chemical system is is capable of
formulating its own expression
and generating a memory and manages its
existence on a planetary body for
billions of years
once we understand
what conditions gave rise to that
we may be very likely to understand
whether a different planet also be
likely to instigate its own chemical
Revolution if it were
it was provided by through some missing
ingredients you can think of it as a
standing fertilizer to a different
planets that is missing its own chemical
composition or lacking or that it needs
more of what it has
the difference between making that
planet Earth like which was this is this
is not what that's about we're not
talking about terraforming or if you're
not talking about turning that planet
into Earth-like system we are talking
about first understanding the planets
studying its chemistry studying its its
properties well enough to understand
whether it is close so it is on chemical
Revolution and maybe giving it that
extra nudge
so this is obviously a pretty big
speculation and suggestion and it's a
very interesting proposition because
this is a yes or no question right this
is this is the ultimate would you rather
it's it's the and I think it says a lot
about
um the perception of the person who is
asking this question that if the answer
is no no no absolutely not that's not
something we want to do I wanna know why
that is the case so just to be clear
what we're talking about is looking at
the chemical cocktail of a particular
planet
yeah and having like tasting it
and seeing uh seeing what's missing so
having a very systematic rigorous
scientific process of understanding what
is missing
not what is missing in terms of to make
it Earth-like but what is missing in
order to be sufficiently uh have the
spark or the capacity of the spark to
launch the uh Evolution Revolution
The evolutionary process exactly so and
then the question is do we want to then
complete the cocktail the proposition is
to also make us think that we will
likely have this capacity at some point
especially when we understand
origin of life better and better right
so we will be asking ourselves this
question I guess I wanted to bring this
to Daylight a little bit because uh
maybe in 10 20 years maybe more so you
wanted to ask the ethical question
should we
of basically start life
Elsewhere on another planet or enable
the the chemicals uh the chemical
capacity of that planet that it may one
day itself get there okay so for me the
answer is yes
so if you were to try to argue against
my yes what would you say why not what's
the worst that could happen
if we seed another planet with life what
are the things we should think about is
your main concern a chemical biological
one or is it an ethical one what do you
think about well the worst thing that
can happen is that it wouldn't work
right so that it's not a
uh likely it's not likely that in
attempts like this would work that's
probably because how do you so you gotta
be very you know you have to have an
understanding that I don't think we have
just yet I see because if it doesn't
work then we could try again right
to me
the worst case the thing I would be
worried about is we create life I mean
the same stuff I worry about like with
plants or
is things that might have a conscious
experience and then
the the dark aspect of life is life is
increasingly complex life
maybe I'm anthropomorphizing but it
seems to have the capacity to suffer huh
and so we're creating something
it's like when you have children you put
creatures into this world
that will suffer can suffer and may
suffer depending on how you view life
may likely suffer and so now you carry
this responsibility for doing your best
to alleviate any suffering they might go
through and that that perhaps that's uh
romanticizing this notion of life
perhaps bacteria are not capable of
suffering but perhaps it'll create more
complex life forms that
would be able to suffer
and that feels like a responsibility as
well of course other people would be
concerned the more obvious concern is
like well you just created a life form
how do you know it's not going to be a
super deadly virus that somehow is able
to hurt humans yeah my my concern is
more I feel like that's a solvable
problem the problem of
creating conscious beings that are able
to suffer that's a tricky one yeah I can
see why because
it goes back to again with
first of all
um
do we have a responsibility to
propagate more of this chemistry that we
have on this planet elsewhere given that
we know ultimately we will be vanished
baby I mean entire planet
and if this is in fact a very rare
chemical events that happens because all
the
right circumstances came together and we
were the lucky one
do we have
a responsibility to sponsor it this is a
if if we were to back up sponsor I like
it let's go where to put it yeah if you
try to uh back up remnants of our
civilization right so we wanna
potentially
creates
conditions on the different planets so
that humans can survive given that we
know or we want to just just for the
sake of
growing yeah propagating uh becoming
multiple terrorist species exactly but
what really is at stake here I think
it's actually or what is really more
interesting is what we don't see which
is the again that the chemical behavior
that enabled everything at first place
that's different than
sending potato crops or engineering
bacteria to live on different planet
that's very different
you're really good stripping it down to
what is like what it what is possible at
the chemical level so even if you are
instigating the con chemistry on
different planets you are letting that
very planet to do its thing you're not
necessarily contaminating this planet
with different chemistry because the
idea behind us at this the way I would I
thought about is that you understand
that planet you understand the
conditions you understand the chemistry
of the planet really well before
choosing the planet as a candidate at
first place and then
it's not about sending a missing
ingredient per se but again just sending
more of what it already has
this that would be respecting that
planet's condition to so I'm not
suggesting any occupation I'm not
suggesting any colonization I'm not
suggesting any like let's just strip
everything and make everything
Earth-like
that's not what I'm saying it's more
about empowering that place
what you are saying is is likely to be
the motivator behind all this let's not
because I see suffering I see pain it's
it's very interesting I think this is a
question that really reveals about a lot
about the person who's answering it well
okay so the pushback on my
pushback
if I so I'm deeply troubled by suffering
then I should be probably paralyzed
about the history of life on Earth
and
um you know there's can you elaborate
what do you mean most of Life who's ever
lived
suffered in ways that are almost
unimaginable to me you mean um like
you're our own species our own species
and before and animals living today and
we're not even talking about factory
farms
uh were just uh animals living in
extreme poverty in the jungle you don't
people think like in a natural
environment animals live in a happy
place no it's a brutal place of
desperately trying to survive of
desperately trying to look for food and
it's just like all of that life that's
just mammals and we understand mammals
but like throughout like trillions of
organisms that led up to those mammals
and the organisms living everywhere like
even bacteria there's death everywhere
so maybe this idea of death this idea of
suffering
is actually this thing that we see as a
bug
is actually a feature
I don't think suffering is a linear
property like that with life
and I may be with Nick Lane on this one
that the likeliness of anything similar
to what we got here evolving in another
planetary body I think is quite low
where would you say is the the biggest
unlikely thing do you mean humans or do
you mean even multicellular organisms
probably multicellular multicellularity
it's uh but
I I understand the
both sides of the
equation right in in one level I can see
that we may not have any other choice
but to
back up this chemistry somewhere else
yeah so you would be saving it's the
ultimate saving or the record our own
record it's not about you know yes let's
also save
um beetles and all the amazing songs but
this would be the ultimate repository of
life
but it's I can also see your point of
view
for sure it's really interesting so like
don't see the plan with the missing
ingredient try to understand what the
ingredients it has
it possible to construct life
uh for me for uh from a computer person
it just feels like something that could
be solved computationally we can learn
from the mistakes that we've done here
and Aspire not to repeat them
it is possible we we do amazing things
as humans there's a lot of suffering but
there's also a lot of beauty and and we
we could choose
what we want to be or what we want to
see right so the these attempts don't
need not to come from not to come from a
place of fear but it can be ultimately
can come from a piece of hope and love I
think we're just very recently figuring
out stuff like we've even just a century
ago we're doing atrocities that uh
weren't seen as atrocities at the time I
mean
I think we're learning very quickly of
what is right and wrong yes and I work
with a lot of maybe because I'm at the
University I get to teach young people
every day
even at a time of four year or three few
years you see
yeah
generational difference already in
unfolding in front of you and maybe
that's why I see hope because I think
what we get to interact with in
classrooms every year it's getting
better they are aware of issues in a way
that I sure wasn't at their age in some
levels I was but in many levels I didn't
think about I I wasn't concerned of the
problems well they maybe have to be
concerned because it's hitting the
reality he's hitting them hard but
younger people are not afraid of these
things an 18 year old can face these
brutal facts about the planet in ways
that I don't think any other generation
before them did yeah it's super cool and
and like the uh
you know there's all these cool
technologies that Aid in the process
of a human being
being able to see the truth the deeper
deeper levels like you know Wikipedia
and just the internet in general is
enabling education a level that was
unimaginable before the internet yes and
I think space exploration even
contemplating about these possibilities
ultimately
and I will emphasize this again should
make us think about our own place in the
universe if we are alone that is quite
fascinating and we definitely have a
responsibility to guard what we got
better and protect it better and don't
take it for granted if we are not the
only one that's also a lot of
responsibility to understand
what else is out there so either
proposition is famously being told is
fascinating but
is a as a scientist I think
and I think that's the general Behavior
maybe not my fellow scientists listening
to this can correct me if they aren't
liked but you need to have a level of
optimism and and hope it that's
something you know that things are work
worth working for worth dreaming worth
imagining and we cannot just have fear
of suffering or fear of pain
stopping us from doing marvelous things
I've talked to quite a few people in my
life who've done who've gotten a lot of
[ __ ] done have helped a lot of people
and I don't know a single one of them
who's not an optimist
now there's a place for critics and
cynicism in this world but in terms of
actually building things and creating
things in this world that help a lot of
people
um I think optimism is a is a
requirement is a precondition in almost
all cases in my Limited
humble Human Experience but I tend to
when I look out there think that aliens
are everywhere I think there's
to me I have a humility about I tend to
see us humans as being very limited
cognitively
like there's so many things we don't
understand
I think eventually we'll understand of
course we don't know this but my gut
says
will understand that alien signals and
life has been all around us
and we're too dumb to see it
like whatever life is whatever the life
force is whatever Consciousness is
whatever intelligence whatever the the
mechanism
that led to the origin of life on Earth
was everywhere
oh we're just too dumb to see it it's in
the physics it's somewhere we'll find it
somewhere in the physics
also being a scientist that we know that
we never know for sure and for the
Outsiders perhaps that may be a very
um strange way of living
especially when your pursue is about
creating knowledge and that you'll know
that what you created can also be and
hopefully will be
disproven so that another level will
rise
um and and I think we've seen that the
this lack of maybe connection between
the approach to science or knowledge
versus uh folks who are maybe not
thinking about these problems every day
that we are okay with being wrong that's
in fact we know that that's the only way
to push the limits of knowledge
how do you think life originated on
Earth we've talked about this a bit do
you have a gut feeling about
first of all actually even to step back
do you think because you were like
flirting with this idea the translation
mechanism came before life
I think that you cannot separate from
translation emergence of translation
Machinery from immersions of life or
something like transition missionary
this whole informatic chemical Computing
system that is also capable of dynamism
and evolvability that comes with Biology
biological behavior from emergence of
life itself we've definitely
took a lot of steps towards
understanding Origins we are able to
create molecules from
right
environments lightning Heat
and you make amino acids so we are able
to create the building blocks the Miller
Yuri experiment that's Now 60 years ago
we are able to uh create the building
blocks we are able to make them interact
with one another they can get more
complex some call this messy there's all
this chemistry that's going on we are
able to
have these chemicals interact with one
another maybe
um
have even some emergent properties that
we can quantify
definitely there is this trend towards
more systems level approach to Origins
with more introduction of systems level
chemistry or network level chemistry uh
and complex system integration in order
to understand how now that we can make
these building blocks we can make them
interact with one another but how do we
make them interact with one another in
more intelligent ways that will
have the properties of a biological
system will be heritable it will be
responding to the environment it will
mutate and it will sustain itself that
is the final bit I think in in our uh
origin of Life Adventure and we are
extremely close I I'm very optimistic
that our community will get a handle of
this problem in in this decade this is
in fact I think one of the most exciting
times to be doing this work what would
be super convincing to you like
incredibly amazing would blow your mind
if it was done
X was done in a lab like what
would yeah I mean I don't know if you
would call it origin of life but
something really truly remarkable and
special done in the lab what would that
look like to you the the
prettiest that I list
this was five properties that I listed
about in the Machinery that is capable
of sensing and responding the
environment if we can
um I would imagine it's similar to
Amelia Yuri experiments where they
on the sparked in a particular
environmental forces and were able to
produce a chemical that is important for
life or a mix of chemicals important for
life or building blocks rather I would
if I saw that a similar experiment there
and well-defined geochemical perimeter
was subjected on a mix of chemistry
which led that chemistry to form some
level of computation informatic
biological property and by biological
I'm going to keep it to very minimum
um as I defined early on
um that would be super exciting to me is
self-organizing chemistry that we can
create experimentally in a flask by
simulating the conditions of early Earth
radiation be it temperature or mix of
both
that would be very cool and doing all
the five the the chemical physical
informatic computational biology yes
so like simulation and a computer would
not no would not be good it would be
great because it's they help to
understand the parameters
maybe formulate maybe quantify create
models But ultimately you need to
experiment unless it's quantum
mechanical simulation but that's going
to be extremely difficult so simulating
from the physics up that's going to be
very because you're going to have to
simulate
the the physical the chemical the
informatic I mean honestly it's it's
very start to it's very difficult to
start the quantum mechanics and end up
in biology all through simulation but
the stuff that deepminded with Alpha
fold and protein folding is really
inspiring it's a
it's inspiring in that you're able to do
to solve a difficult biology yeah
absolutely that's that's why there's
definitely a lot of benefits to those
models predictions because they at least
help the experiment experimentalists to
come up with the priors and parameterize
things better maybe eliminates very
obvious dead ends early on given that
experiments take such a long time and
it's a huge investment
um and no one's a better experimentalist
than nature so let me let me ask you
perhaps a depressing sad for you
question really want to make me sad
you're not going to win no I know
there's a flame of optimism in you that
will never be extinguished